I hey guys I'm I'm currently make up DUP
with matpat hey hey subscribe to me not
him anyway so can subscribe to me though
like it pitty subscribe pitty system
yeah don't do that
anyway so we're here on a big set and if
it's not obvious there's a lot of are we
even allowed to talk about this I have
no idea we're allowed to talk about it
but we're not allowed to reveal any wide
shots of the fields or who wins swag
swag swag slug holes there's Lexie this
is like the designated squiggles waggles
main squad goals Oh face squiggles hash
tag swag oh these are called hard foam
weapons so what you have is something
that looks a lot like iron I think this
is actually proper in the movie you can
hit yourself on out that actually hurts
markiplier educational blog you can see
I just said they hit me over the head
you experienced it with me if you're
gonna be in a video I I happen to get
hurt in a lot of videos we suffer for
our art make another staff video yes
more [ __ ] here oh and I'm in my swag
gear so this mic swag swag okay anyway
[ __ ] you brilliant this is the BTS guy
he's been following me around like a
creeper now Oh behind-the-scenes ception
oh yeah my objective here is just to
ruin in all of his shots yeah exactly I
won't be able to hit the D key anymore I
can't turn right I'm not an Andy Turner
okay so I'm over on the Horde side now
and you can tell it's stupider cuz it's
just rocks and dirt and a whole bunch of
other crap and the weapons are cool
though okay what's up what's up I'm here
with Jordan
I thought originally he was on the
opposite team so I called him the [ __ ]
loser right as soon as you walk in the
door I haven't changed my mind about
that but he's on my team so he's gonna
be yeah you're gonna be on the front
lines I'm gonna have you leading the vid
clear there's a throne on the Horde side
I want to drag it onto our Hill and just
sit by the flag all relaxed though my
subjects we're not actually murdering
people at least yeah I mean I you know
they're not human they're hard right and
that's the only thing that matter where
the disgusting reality of markiplier
sets in how horrible a person I actually
am okay so if the Alliance wasn't badass
enough as it is they equipped us with
stylish fanny pack ammo ammo packs all
fanny packs to hold our ammo so we're
gonna we're gonna be doing wonderfully
it's good they they get shoulder pads
shoulder pads
yo yo yo what is your board right hand
mark EMU swag don't think I've ever worn
all white my entire life they're warm
pants in your entire life no I have it's
a monument I look into your camera you
look into my eye
yo we're bout to rock it in the game a
flag century the flag girl let's run it
whatever this game's called for Warcraft
yeah shout out your YouTube channel
youtube.com slash opposing team they're
probably gonna win I mean we're not
playing to win here our team is so much
change your team it's cool like we're
gonna win because on the the people
watching are gonna be we're the heart of
the champion you gotta rise above the
hate it's understandable right I mean
you guys Alliance you get you saw the
dance understandable I mean we're
huggers we believe in like caressing
people we're gonna feed gentle kisses
you know these racial roosterteeth I
just said it
we're gonna hug them we're gonna embrace
them close you know show love not hate
we're gonna be embracing all the enemies
it's gonna be totally fun hey I'm with
my true brothers if they win I was
encouraging all along red hair obviously
unfortunately I was made team captain of
the Alliance and we're obviously gonna
lose like it's just a given like when
can we win so it's gonna be cool we're
gonna pull up a show everyone's gonna
shout out you know subscribe to
markiplier and it's gonna be great
subscribe really arty good yeah yeah
adore I'll make sure we lose I'll make
sure we subscribe to cutie pie he's he
needs it really need him we're gonna
lose link okay I'm kind of done I won't
tell you who won because it can but it
was a freaking war it was in endeavour
what the Frick is going on it was bad
man I don't fill a lot of balls and I
got hit by a few more so you know do
subscribe